[MUSIC PLAYING]
[PIANO MUSIC PLAYING]
MORGAN FREEMAN: I'm going
to tell you right now,
acting is not something
you can really teach.
Technique you can.
But the actual art, you can't.
HALLIE MEYERS-SHYER: Want me
to teach Jon the bend-and-snap?
OK.
OK-- and then you snap.
Yes!
PHOEBE ROBINSON:
If you think you
have a story to tell
that's worth hearing,
you're probably right.
So you should just go for it.
It doesn't matter if there's
not an example there--
a blueprint-- for you to follow.
You can be the first one.
And you can kind of figure
things out yourself.
WYCLEF JEAN: (SINGING)
Every time I make a run,
girl, you turn around and cry.
I ask myself, why, o, why.
TONY PATRICK: You're mistaking
whatever the current trend
in thought is for knowing more.
Sometimes, people are
wrong for millennia.
JAMES MONROE: I'm actually
having a very long conversation
with Daveed.
And Daveed said, no, man.
Look, bring your
swagger to the show.
And I was like, are you sure?
(SINGING) I'm running my
radar when Bonnie comes by.
CAST: (SINGING) Come on back.
CAST: (SINGING) --in
the circle of life.
[MUSIC - G. LOVE]
GAELYNN LEA: The problem
isn't the disability itself.
It's society's inaccessibility.
And when you reframe it that
way, it takes away the pity.
And it also puts
responsibility on society
to make sure that they're doing
a good job of being accessible.
IRENE ZISBLATT: The Holocaust
is not just a part of history.
But it lingers in the present.
Perhaps, when we were forgetting
how powerful hatred can be,
9/11 reminded us.
DIANNA COWERN: I had some
really awesome physics teachers.
So never--
SPEAKER: I know.
DIANNA COWERN:
--underestimate the value
of what you can do to
instill the curiosity
and the excitement on the
young people in your life.
WILLIAM MCDONOUGH: We want to
make imagination enhancers,
systems that help people
become better thinkers,
independently of the
system they're using.
YANN ARTHUS BERTRAND:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
AL GORE: Successfully
resolving this
is the key to redeeming
our destiny as human beings
and saying to the
generations that follow,
we did the right thing.
MICHAEL J. FOX: No one
dies from Parkinson's.
You die with Parkinson's.
And so I'm living
with Parkinson's.
ANTHONY BOURDAIN:
Well, I was quite sure,
when I wrote "Kitchen
Confidential," that no one was
going to read it.
And that was a very
liberating thing
because I didn't have
the burden of trying
to imagine what
people would expect,
or what they might
like or dislike,
or what the market wanted.
I wasn't thinking about
any of those things.
YIN PIN XIU:
THOMAS L. FRIEDMAN: Then, when
you press the Pause button
on a computer, it stops.
But when you press the Pause
button on a human being,
it starts.
ANNA AKBARI: You don't
even know if you're
going to be around tomorrow.
So you have to find a way to
be happy along the journey.
RIC FLAIR: And you guys will
be going 200 miles-an-hour
around a track.
And I'll be going, whoo!
ATUL GAWANDE: Thank you for
taking time on your lunch
to come talk about death.
MARTIN ATKINS: Just be nice.
The good thing is, there are
some people being nice to them.
You don't have to
buy them a car.
And if someone's at
that point where you've
got to buy a car for them
to go, thanks for the car,
the car isn't going to
make a difference anyway.
ORIT KOPE: When you're talking
about Trump and Hillary--
there are so many more stories
around the world happening--
terror attacks in Egypt and
so on-- that people do talk,
but maybe not enough.
SIMON SINEK: I wish all
organizations-- they
don't have to be nation-states.
I wish all organizations
did the same thing,
operated not just
in their interest,
but also have a sense
of code or values
and a sense of
purpose and vision.
IRENE VILLA: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
LUVVIE AJAYI: America
does not do a good job
looking at itself in the
mirror and being like, oh, OK.
I see what's coming back at me.
RUSSELL BRAND: If
you don't acknowledge
you've got a problem,
how can you intervene
in your own consciousness?
You have to intervene.
This is the problem.
Second, you have to believe
that change is possible.
Right?
You have to be open to the
possibility of new data.
OMAR SAIF GHOBASH:
I keep coming back
to the idea of how
technology changes
our, perhaps, psychology,
how it changes
our relationship to each other.
NOAM CHOMSKY: How did we
develop creative capacities
of a unique kind which have led
to extraordinary achievements?
OK, these are things
we would ought
to try and understand,
all of them,
and then do something about
them, not just understand.
[MUSIC PLAYING]